Speaker 1: Let's get to this week's mailbag. You
can email in info at David Pakman dot com. Also
random youtube posts comments rather or reddit
posts or whatever else might end up being featured
in this segment. And no shortage of different
topics to look at many substantive, which I know
many of you have been saying, David, I prefer the
substantive emails and comments that you display.
We have quite a mix today, that's for sure. Jamie
wrote in, Jamie says, Hey, David, I don't usually
write in, but I just had to after this. I watch
your content regularly and so your videos show
up in my recommendation feed on YouTube. One clip
that you posted earlier today, this was last late
last week was soaking wet. Trump Explodes Walks
Out of Piers Morgan interview. But the phrasing of
soaking wet Trump explodes brings a very different
mental image to mind. This happened in another
one of your segments when you were commenting on
Trump's religiosity, where you said, I don't think
Trump has ever gotten on his knees for Jesus,
which again brings a very different mental image
to mind. If it's intentional, I love it. But if
it's not, I thought I would let you know. Now,
Jamie, we know exactly what we're doing. We know
exactly what we're doing. And I absolutely love
love this email. This this is on this email is
genius on about three or four different levels.
And I couldn't thank you enough for it, Jamie.
But yes, no, those the titles are not an accident.
Then go from Norway wrote in and WinCo says David,
first off, great show. I'm a loyal listener and
subscriber and American expat living in Norway.
Can you speak? I know, by the way, I know the
term expat is very controversial with some in our
audience, but I'm reading the email as written.
Can you spare a minute to explain why some
people refer to Ukraine as Ukraine and others as
though Ukraine? Many thanks and keep up
the great work. I seriously appreciate
your insight on current events. So the
Ukraine is a reference to the Soviet era
where when you say the Ukraine, you're sort of
saying the borderlands. And so the reason that
I don't say the Ukraine and I understand it's
really not correct to say the Ukraine anymore
is that the country as it exists
today, as an independent country,
at least for now, we'll see what Putin gets away
with is that it's it's the country, Ukraine.
If we say the Ukraine, it would be sort of like
saying the outskirts or the borderlands of the
Soviet Union rather than an independent country.
And those are the historical origins of that.
I say Ukraine, I believe it is correct to say
Ukraine. Brian Rhoden This is so funny. You guys
will understand why in a second. Brian says, Hey,
David, I'm Brian from Toronto. I love the show.
The other day you mentioned your agent and
you had a discussion on getting a package
to send to CNN Plus. But you were thinking it's
a poor idea. Correct me if I'm wrong, however,
I think it would be a great move. CNN Plus is
likely under immense pressure right now. You
could have a great opportunity to bring success
to the platform, demonstrate the proven content,
make changes from the inside. Plus, the contracts
they're giving out aren't too bad either. You can
negotiate from a place of power as your numbers
are already proven. CNN Plus has since shut down
like as as quickly as I told the story to the
audience. Wow. CNN Plus isn't doing great.
They're only getting about 10,000 viewers a
day. We get way more than that. And it's like
also lame that my agent and I didn't
even think to send a proposal to them,
in part because I don't want to have 20 bosses.
It's more more about that. Brian's like, No, it
might be a good idea. And in the three days since
there's been an announcement that CNN Plus is just
shutting down and that's the right decision,
and it is a humiliating expenditure of money
for nothing to show for it. I know I've said this
before. Many of you are probably getting tired
if CNN took a fraction of what they spent on CNN
Plus and just said, hey, we're going to pick the
top ten like YouTube and podcast shows in the
political space. And we're going to give them
a fraction of the money just to, like, buy ads
on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook. The return on
investment would have been dramatically better,
dramatically better. But sadly, Brian, there's
no more conversation to have because CNN Plus is
going bye bye. Kevin wrote in about Trump 2024.
Kevin says, I doubt that Trump runs in 2024. He
will blame health or claim it won't be a fair
election. Trump is too big of a coward to risk
losing again. I do think it would be interesting
to have a debate between two people that have
been president. A normal debate, the candidates
answer as to what they would do. This debate, each
candidate has an actual record. I completely agree
that a debate. Now, is it true we think about
that? Has there ever been a debate between.
I think that's probably true, but I'd have to
actually look at the history books on that.
But let's assume it's true that Biden
versus Trump would be the first the campaign
where both candidates have been president. I
think that would be interesting. But I also
I mean, listen, to be honest, I worry if Trump
runs and is the Republican nominee. I worry that
he wins and that it's a really bad four years
for the planet and for the country and for so
many different people. So my preference would
be that Trump not even run. It's not that I'm
scared of Trump. I think the risk is
the same with DeSantis. And by the way,
I think the Santos would be more dangerous because
the Santos is less incompetent. But my preference
would be that both options in 2024 aren't as bad
as Trump, and Trump is starting to mention health,
and that's not something he previously did. So
Kevin may be on to something there. Next message
is from Ross. Ross continues to wait, I guess,
for the big smoking gun revelation about 2020.
Ross says Biden can't even get ten people at a
rally. Everyone knows the Dems and dark money
along with Republican RINO's rigged the election.
It will come out in due time. My question now for
the it's eventually going to come out people is
to say how long is it going to take? We are now
4 to 6. We're 18 months now beyond the
2020 election. Hard to believe, but we are
and we still have no evidence of the fraud that
they are convinced exists. So with peace and love
and respect and honesty, I want to know how
long is it going to take? Ross Let me know.
Chicken wrote in about food shortages and said
this summer, this is a prediction, I guess, from
chicken this summer when you can't afford food or
there is no food. We'll all be laughing at you.
Liberals are the Capitol are real
Nazis. Liberals are the Ku Klux Klan.
Check your history if you can read losers
with a Capital L. Listen. I mean, this is
I'm going to ignore the innuendo and the ad
hominem. I just have a different opinion. I've
been researching the possibility of food shortages
for, you know, ten days now and did a story on it
for you guys last week. I believe there will
be some products with limited availability.
You know, if you're obsessed with if you're
obsessed with a certain freezer waffle,
you might have to choose a different
freezer waffle regionally and sporadically.
But there aren't going to be shortages of any food
group for sure, based on everything I'm reading.
Maybe I'm wrong. You know, we don't have to
call people Nazis to say I have a different
opinion. I just think chicken is wrong here.
Harrison wrote in about book banning and says,
Liberate this. This is a genius. This is genius.
If it weren't so dangerous, this would be genius,
Harrison says. Liberals are for banning books
just as much as conservatives. Any serious
liberal doesn't want public school teachers
teaching lessons from the Bible. You know
what? Harrison That's right. And it's not about
banning the Bible. It's that we have separation
of church and state. Public schools are funded
by property taxes and other funds from states,
meaning that there has to be separation between
church and state. You can't have a public school
where everybody goes of no religion and
of any religion and say, We're going to
teach the Bible here. Now, if you want to have a
comparative religion class in a public school and
maybe some high schools have such classes using
religious texts, they're not to teach them as true
substance, but to teach what is in them and say,
Here's what the Old Testament Hebrew Bible says.
Here's what the New Testament says. Here's
the Koran. Here's the Spaghetti Monster thing,
and here's the Greek stuff. You could do that in
comparative religion as a history class of sorts.
But no, it's it's against the law to teach lessons
from the Bible, as in, here's what we learn from
the story of Noah's Ark. Here is what we learn
about homosexuality or whether you should eat
shrimp or and that is against the law. You can't
do that. So, yes. Harrison People who follow the
law are against that. Groucho wrote in and says
the internet was and is way too much for low
intelligence folks. Most of these people are holed
away in the same small town they were born in.
Completely terrified of leaving. No. Now they
have all this crazy info from snake oil salesman
at their fingertips, and it has kicked their
paranoia into overdrive. You're you're basically
describing the way reactionary politics works.
I mean, Groucho's using provocative language,
but Groucho is completely correct. You have
sheltered people who, through a combination
of a lack of economic means in some cases,
and bad parenting. And, you know, I mean,
we got to kind of tell it like it is.
People end up extraordinarily sheltered
and then they are targeted with fear based
rhetoric and they fall for it. And then they go on
Facebook and they post it. And then that creates
this echo chamber and filter bubble where they
get more of the same stuff. Next thing you know,
you're drinking urine. You know, that's it's a sad
reality. But Groucho is spot on. And lastly,
Terry says David Pakman will support the war
until the last Ukrainian is dead. The war pig
pacman is so brave. I actually don't know where
this is coming from, but the last week or so, I've
been getting more and more comments and questions
that seem to assume I support the Russian
invasion of Ukraine. I've never said anything
to suggest that. I obviously don't support the
Russian invasion of Ukraine, and quite frankly,
I would love for people to knock it off because
it's just a waste of time. I don't support the
Russian invasion of Ukraine, so I don't know
why you would come to me and tell me that I do.
If you have a comment that you'd like to
see featured, you can email info at David
Pakman dot com. We have a fantastic bonus show for
you today. Become a member. Really? There is no
better time. April. Beautiful month to do it. Sign
up at join pacman dot com. You'll get access to
the bonus show. You'll get The Daily Show 6 hours
before everybody else. It's a beautiful thing.